jacques amyot
mais je la fais pas de problème vraiment
je suis prêteuses mois calvillo est ce
que pouvez vous mettre au milieu qu'on a
qu'on en profite un peu fou ça m'énerve
un peu
quelle trace résiste du cirque de pékin
dans 20 minutes sous antibiotiques lui
par exemple bon l'irish poker dans une
interview ma main je ne sais pas ça
dépend comment dans une fraude l'année
toutes ses fringues après prévert après
le théâtre et avant holiday on ice vous
revenez liot avec un album cd qui
s'appelle dit au prince charmant c'est
chery cole warner mais avant de parler
de vos nouvelles chansons je voudrais
qu'on écoute les anciennes
m
oh
c'est vrai
m
je cite avait tonné
je partage ton
imagine que tu ajoutes ont une image
rien
la page
inquiétant
comment
non trop tard
non fortement les pattes
m
les bonnes mesures
j'ai pu voir
alors je connais un peu loiseau
non
ça reste un premier temps pas tout le
temps
l'essentiel
et en sélection
t'aimes pas les brunes terme ou re de
françoise 1 ça vous plaît michel non à
vous aviez pas dans les chansons vous
étiez de construire et lui sont des
merveilleux souvenir n'est ce pas bien
alors je voudrais signaler la sortie
d'un coffret lio chéhéry corde il ya
tous vos albums plus un dvd de clips
si une manière un peu de lutter contre
les compilations pourri ben oui peut se
sait pas toujours très agréable de voir
les choses disséquer remise à gauche à
droite sont qu'on ait son mot à dire
et puis a eu ya eu un jugement qui a été
rendu par la cour de cassation c'est le
jugement
jean ferrat qui a dit qu'une oeuvre
était une oeuvre qu'on pouvait pas comme
celle à dissocier la m un peu on voulait
et donc depuis effectivement sans son
autorisation de l'artiste son appui
droite découper des disques et de vendre
des chansons à gauche à droite et c'est
vrai que j'avais envie même si c'était
pas du tout pour gagner des sous parce
qu'avec série gore tu en gagnes pas de
souche connaît très bien l'individu qui
dirait je dirais corde puisque c'est le
regard de ma fille j'ai jamais vu un
certain donc je ne verrai jamais un sou
mais ça c'est pas grave parce que la vie
continue il ya de l'amour
et puis surtout il assez les arts
graphiques qui fait des très belles
pochettes la mal passé mais je vais te
donne est donc à coffrer lio pour tous
ce que ça ça intéresse alors nous avait
vendu des millions de disques et
pourtant ce dans une carrière assez
chaotique finalement vous dites je suis
le cauchemar parfait d'un directeur de
marketing
j'ai un potentiel commercial énorme et
je suis ingérable
c'est à dire c'est eux qui le disent
mais comme moi je trouve qu'on gère un
agenda est pas une personne je prouve
que c'est leur problème coin en gros
donc ils m'ont rendu le contrat
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont les plus forts
ouais ouais c'est pas grave c'est juste
les difficiles de la vie vous dites à 43
ans changerait pas personne ne m'a
jamais domestique et je resterai un
petit animal sauvage celle ci d'un petit
animal sauvage et d'ailleurs on
m'appelle la belette à la belote dans la
dignité
la belette dans l'intimité oui ma part
je pouvais aussi intime pourtant c'est
vrai que votre attitude facilite pas les
choses
par exemple l'album là qui vous amène
dit prince charmant c'est un budget de
30 mille euros paul chute comprise
mais c'est ça vous embête pas travailler
si peu de moyens non pas du tout c'est d
aventure formidable à chaque fois c'est
très très drôle
c'est un cadeau de votre fiancé le papa
de diego la production de son fils et
puis pas que ça aussi tout ce que j'ai
fait depuis trois ans c'est quand même
lui qui est derrière
derrière tout ça pour l'enregistrer j'ai
deux parties à malmö on a le et
maintenant s'il vous plaît vous
m'appelez lieu vous êtes parti en suède
parce que les studios et c'est trop cher
en angleterre c'est sage époux et non
pas ce cas d'erreur c'est effectivement
très cher mais finalement ce qu'on
voulait c'était une consonne analogique
en voulait un son chaleureux pas quelque
chose qu'il soit dénué de bain
d'humanité finalement et malmö ben
c'était pas cher c'était joli c'était
vraiment une cabane de vue soit au
milieu de la forêt vous avez été une
belle aventure et vous faites la
tambouille pendant l'enregistrement
on ne fait pas que ça hein excusez moi
je ne sais pas que ça j'ai d'autres
talents mais je fais la tambouille
excellemment d'ailleurs comme nous
avions un végétarien par exemple je me
suis spécialisé dans les pattes au
brocoli j'ai fait très bien les pattes
michel qui peut penser magnifiquement
l'ensemble de la cuisine et rocco non
mais c'est pas dommage d'être obligé de
faire la rythmique de 14 morceaux en
quinze jours
non c'est un autre truc c'est un
challenge moi je me rappelle du premier
film de jim jarmusch il avait pas
d'argent il a fait très vite c'était un
pur chef-d'oeuvre dont ça dépend je
manque de moyens n'a pas été gênant
présente qu'on vous vous retrouvez à
berlin dans une chambre pour faire les
voix avec un matelas collé au mur pour
pour l'acoustique ça oui et je ne vous
en faites quoi
mais pas du tout mais vous imaginez un
petit peu ce que j'aurais à raconter à
des petits enfants quand une vieille
dame venue
dunk ont été enregistrés dans les
toilettes au d'épuiser salle devant une
très bonne acoustique ya plein de vie ça
aussi ce secteur enregistre énormément
dans les salles de bains les rolex tout
ça voilà donc maintenant c'est payet
j'ai appris du temps comme pour vous y
mettre
cet album qu'en cinq ans pourquoi parce
que je me relevais d'une histoire
d'amour absolument exécrable que j'avais
de deux des jumelles en bas âge que je
me faisais plus du tout confiance j'ai
un gros problème de peur en fait et de
confiance en moi et que ma il a fallu
qu'on que petit à petit alarmante quoi
et ça n'a pas été évident ça et au début
vous plantez les séances de travail on
m'appelait papillon papillon je trouve
que c'est assez joli pas ce que ça veut
dire qu'on vous accable pas de votre
manque c'est ça veut dire qu'on accepte
comme un moment sans vous dire que vous
êtes réellement une [ __ ] et ça c'est
vachement est vachement dit c'est vrai
donc la belette et papillon oui y'a quoi
d'autres invités l'idéal était docteur
que je qu'il est fort très fort
alors l'album s'appelle dit au prince
charmant donc l'idée c'est de tordre le
cou à ce concept de de prince charmant
qui finalement font très noir m'énerve
qu'ils auraient été très très très très
bien à nurenberg au milieu des autres
crimes contre l'humanité je trouve que
de vendre la romance comme ça pour
asservir les femmes les femmes qui ne
qui ne peuvent que se réveiller quand un
homme se penche sur elles et leur donne
un baiser ça me gave un peu mais j'ai
utilisé des leçons de mulhouse sommes
que le prince charmant carrément moi je
pense que c'est très très bien de tordre
le cou aux illusions mais de croire au
rêve le rêve c'est quelque chose de
dynamique à partir du moment où le rêve
d'apprendre le pense et qu'après on le
fait parce qu'il suffit pas de rester
dans donc dans les nimbes d'une vraie
c'est quand même vraiment quelque chose
qui vous met en dynamique de vie tandis
qu illusion c'est le mot le mouroir
c'est le miroir aux alouettes où vous
vous noyez est ce que je remarque et sa
matrice est l'humanité préfère tordre le
cou aux rêves collusion et c'est pour ça
que ça va pas et quant aux 10 les sims
que le féminisme a échoué elle donne
comme exemple bridget jones
ce qu'elle dit voilà si le livre le plus
lu par les femmes et le plus couru par
les fans
c'est une trentenaire qui ne peut pas
vivre sans trouver lors de sa vie et
sans maigrir pour ressembler à kate moss
est ce que vous avez été sensible au
prince charmant goût assumé tout à
l'heure l abri des deux camps soient
mieux respirer un peu fort quand vous
avez rencontré guy de panafieu est ce
que pour vous c'était le prince charmant
françoise ça je craque alors là chacun
son sale goût vous savez des princes
charmants il y en a plein la terre et y
a pas de cas des princes
oui bon il ya des hommes séduisants oui
mais très bien moi je suis pour les
hommes séduisants voilà et qui sont
intéressants sexuellement ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'ils ont des entrées son mari
par exemple
we will you you polimeks de pareils
parce que vous allez le prince charmant
nous on a la belle au bois dormant donc
c'est mon enfant dort pas les combats
chéri
les hommes ne vont si bien c'est le
premier single de dit au prince charmant
le nouvel album de lil chery cole warner
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble vous
allez regarder votre caméra mais à celle
là c'est le cas le rouge
ouais bon jour et vous dites lieux y
vient vous dites magnéto manier te mana
mineurs allèrent jeu malaisie manitou
sert je vois là